[Music]
at the free-throw line
again as scalp pointed out earlier has
taken his game out beyond
the three-point line now can play that
uh
renegade five position yeah just move
the ball space the floor
and with their team and the guards that
can get to the paint
it's a nice position to be the defense
on its heels and
you hear the ovation in the background
and that is because andre
roberson is going to check into the game
for the first time and he's going to
check in
to any kind of competitive game for the
first time since january 27th
of 2018 all of his teammates
on their feet giving him a big round of
applause and mike what a moment
for andre roberson getting into live
game action
and the long road to recovery that he
has been on
and it's got to feel good for him to get
finally back out on the floor i'm sure
it's very emotional as well man i got
chills just seeing him step on the floor
after two and a half years and i was
certainly there
on that very unfaithful night in detroit
where the injury occurred
and to see him step on that floor man
what a great story he is as well
long time thunder player as well
it is a story of persevere every
possession
defensively can you move your feet do
you have versatility offensively what do
you provide for your
for your guys a lot of stuff
[Applause]
67 viewers with a lot of money you tend
to forget about him a little bit
he's a solid player yeah i don't i think
in the playoffs he's gonna
there's gonna be opportunities where you
need his defense and his poise
engaged they are totally into dre
and what he's doing out there on the
floor folks